wir haben einen neuen bundestag wir
haben sie bei 36 abgeordnete von denen
verdient jeder im monat 10.000 euro und
wenn man die extras dazu nimmt wie die
steuerfreie aufwandspauschale und die
gute altersversorgung so ist das
entspricht ein brutto jahresgehalt von
etwa 250.000 euro
ich bin nicht der meinung dass es zu
viel ist alle abgeordneten müssen gut
bezahlt sondern die haben eine hohe
verantwortung aller ruhe aber ist das
alles noch was mich stört ist dass ein
wachsender anteil von abgeordneten
direkt in den bundestag kommt aus der
schule aus einer berufstätigkeit die
nicht zu definieren ist
vom studium meist abgebrochen und dann
auf steigt über nacht in die gruppe der
oberen zwei bis drei prozent der
spitzenverdiener in deutschland so und
dann bin ich der meinung eigentlich
alles rot gesetzt sagt die abgeordnete
sollen angemessen entschädigt werden
entschädigt werden dafür dass das nicht
verdienen können was ich dir verdient
haben aber kann ich einen bafög
empfänger 800 euro entschädigen 20.000
monat das sagt ist eigentlich ganz im
sinne des erfinders ist
vorschlag eigentlich wir bekämen eine
ganz andere struktur im bundestag wenn
ein abgeordneter
so vergütet würde das so bezahlt wird
was irgendwie durch die der letzten fünf
jahre verdient hat
da dürfte für manche die tätigkeit gar
nicht mehr attraktiv sein und
wir bekämen meine ich auch eine andere
qualität wie auch mehr leute mit
berufserfahrung mit leuten die auch
wissen dass sozusagen umsatz und gewinn
zwei stufen sind der umsatz nicht höher
sein kann der gewinner sein kann als der
umsatz und das aufträge und
arbeitsplätze das noch hin und also ich
glaube das parlament während näher an
der wirklichkeit wenn wir die zahlen das
waren also ich glaube die frage die
dahinter steht ist ja wirklich die frage
der abhängigkeit von abgeordneten bin
ich abhängig von dieser position von dem
mandat heißt unterwerfe ich mich
tatsächlich der fraktions oder
parteilinie oder mache ich das im
bundestag wofür ich auch gewählt wurde
nämlich dem bürgerwillen dort zu
vertreten und kompetenz und ja die
beiden fragen die dahinter stehen und
ich glaube da gibt es einen besseren und
anderen weg über den wir dringend reden
müssen zum einen ist es
gerade was die exekutive betrifft
amtszeit begrenzung und das andere ist
ob das wahlsystem nicht hinterfragt
werden muss und wir sagen dass wirklich
nur noch und ausschließlich direkt
gewählte abgeordnete in den bundestag
einziehen weil dann müssen sie sich
bewähren im wahlkreis selbst und denn
der wähler so entscheidet und sagt er
macht hier richtig guten job dann kann
er auch gut bezahlt werden gut ist das
wahlrecht ist ich bin auch wegen des
mehrheitswahlrechts aber dass das ist
das kriegen wir nicht hin weil bei
unserer bereit struktur keine mehrheit
dafür nur was die abhängigkeit angeht
jemand der von der uni bonn exam ohne
beruf in den bundestag geht dort acht
jahre ist und zu fürchten muss nicht
wieder aufgestellt zu werden und geführt
sind ja momentan relativ viele da
reinhold ihn also
nicht der ist im höchsten maße abhängig
und zwar von der fraktionsführung das
ist angeordnet er ist wachsen in den
händen der bei der führenden funktionäre
denn der muss machen was die sagen sonst
nämlich nicht mehr aufgestellt und
bekommt nicht wer seinen listenplatz und
das ist halt das ist nicht die
unabhängigkeit die das grundgesetz
eigentlich vorsieht für die abgeordneten
apropos unabhängigkeit was ich spannend
finde wenn man sich mit
spitzenpolitikern unterhält in diesen
tagen aus der ampel dann sagen ganz
viele dass sie wahnsinnig angst davor
haben was diese grüne jugend und die
die
jusos bundestag veranstalten werden und
was sie dann am ende abstimmung wie sie
abstimmen und so weiter also gibt es
einen riesen unsicherheit was mit diesen
newcomern da im bundestag wirklich
passiert war die gibt's bei mir ehrlich
gesagt auch und trotzdem möchte ich die
jungen leute nicht ausschaffen aus dem
bundestag und ich glaube wenn wir zu
ihrem vorschlag kommen müller vogg dann
entledigen wir uns mal ganz elegant ganz
vieler junger abgeordneter die übrigens
auch mit talent durchaus in diesem
bundestag einziehen können und dass die
alten dann so unter sich sind das möchte
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht erleben ich
würde sogar behaupten es gibt ganz viele
alte die dann nur noch ihre zeit
absitzen die nehme ich das gewohnt sind
dass sie im bundestag sitzen und ich
werde jeden tag für ihr mandat mal sehen
was aus seiner asche zum beispiel wird
als hinterbänkler ich mal sehen was aus
dem wird ja herr schulz hat glaube ich
auch zuletzt seien derzeit ab das nicht
glaube auch herr gabriel hat relativ
lange nach hinten gesetzt so eine
stiftung die nicht oder so es gibt diese
abgeordnete deswegen ich glaube dass der
der vorschlag ich halte ihn für in
teilen absurd wenn ich das sagen dafür
müller vogg das tut mir leid weil es
junge leute aus dem bundestag aus dank
ich stimme ihnen aber doch in einem ganz
wesentlichen punkt ihrer argumentation
zu nämlich dass es natürlich ganz viele
abgeordnete gibt die ihr geld nicht wert
sind die ihren job nicht ordentlich
machen und ich glaube dazu wäre die
lösung den bundestag einfach zu
verkleinern das würde nämlich mehr
qualität und weniger kann ist also muss
man aufpassen gerade die kleineren
parteien aber auch spd und grüne wollten
den bundestag dahingehend verkleinern
tatsächlich die direktwahlkreise zu
beschneiden und das bringt wieder mehr
abhängigkeit von liszt und partei und da
merkt man in welche richtung das geht
deswegen noch mal die direkt gewählten
abgeordneten sind die die auch am
unabhängigsten massiven vorteil für sie
als cdu darf man an der stelle auch
nicht verlangen nicht mehr nicht mehr
nicht ja dieses mal war es nicht so ich
habe meinen wahlkreis auch nicht direkt
gewonnen gegen olaf scholz und annalena
baerbock
schwierig aber trotzdem ich halte es
trotzdem für das richtige signal an der
stelle und da muss man jetzt bei der
diskussion aufpassen wenn der bundestag
verkleinert werde nur guten argumente
rheine keine jungen mehr also
in die leute ihr examen machen beruf
ausüben und 30 dem bundestag geben wäre
das keine vergreisung des bundestags
also zu sagen weil irgendeiner 23 ist
oder 25 und studiert schon 15 semester
ohne erfolg es hat deshalb eine
intellektuelle bereicherung für das
parlament das halte ich auch ein
bisschen
etwas übertrieben also ich finde aber
ich finde den vorschlag von hugo
müller-vogg ich muss das hier
verteidigen ich finde es eine
punktlandung
weil das problem und das sehen sie nicht
nur in deutschland das sehen sie bei
vielen parlamenten bei diesen berufs
parlamenten was die politiker eine
interessensgruppe bilden eine gruppe die
ein interesse daran hat vom staat
möglichst viele privilegien geld zu
kassieren die sind materiell abhängig
vom staat um vor allen diese politiker
spüren ja die auswirkung ihrer eigenen
politik nicht die können schon eine
klima politik entscheidet die 30.000
leuten bei vw den job kostet sie selbst
bekommen sie ihren luxuriösen lohn und
ich glaube das ist ein echtes problem
und die behauptung dass man sagt ja man
findet dann keine guten leute mehr wenn
ein hoher lohn bezahlt wird das stimmt
gar nicht weil politiker wenn sie es gut
machen können auch nach ihrer karriere
zum teil unglaubliche jobs sich können
unglaubliche dinge tun sie lernen so
viele menschen kennen und
wir haben in italien ist die karikatur
eines solchen parlamentarischen systems
wo am schluss die parlamentarier zum
teil dreifache pensionsansprüche hat das
war obst in italien kommt also der
politiker mit der bursche und der
unternehmer kommt mit dem hyundai das
ist ja quasi die situation dort und da
mussten sie über die bücher so ist nicht
in deutschland aufnehmen die sich
passend ich habe uns information für
relativ das problem dass sie hier eine
abgehobene blase haben die an der
wirklichkeit der lebenswirklichkeit der
leute vorbei politisiert ist mit diesen
bezüge natürlich sehr groß deshalb finde
ich ihren vorschlag finde ich sehr sehr
bedenkenswert ich setze mich in der
schweizer auch dafür ein dass die bezüge
der parlamentarier reduziert werden wir
haben ja nicht mal der berufs parlament
aber faktisch haben wir auch schon eins
und selbst eine deckelung nach oben bei
ihnen herr müller wie oder würde herr
merz nach richtiger
mann sind nach oben denke ich man könnte
natürlich auch sagen es steigt nach wie
der zweite periode oder selbst dabei nur
das prinzip da sozusagen leute
ein anreiz ist für junge leute zu sagen
statt einstufen wie mein studium sie
können sonst was
nutze ich das was ich gelernt habe
nämlich alle innerparteilichen tricks
über mehrheit bildet wie man koalitionen
geschmiedet wie man intelligent
anzetteln vögel abwehrt und kommt ins
parlament und habe dann sozusagen in auf
der ebene von geschäftsführer und
manager in mittelständischen unternehmen
oder etwa zwei ebenen großkonzern
direkt von aus dem hörsaal auf ihre
finanziell dass das muss die leute ja
auch irgendwie beeinflussen und zwar
nicht positiv